creepy makes not what they used to be
well they're not and there's been a
quite for or a um over the past year
since Kabri zone and Mondelez announced
that it was changing the recipe but
Cadbury on the other hand does actually
say it's quite a vocal minority who are
up in arms about it and that there's
actually wider market trends which are
affecting the sales of its products like
what well if we look at the market in
general grocery it's going to come as no
surprise that Aldi and little snapping
up growing share so we got that which
tends to be Aldean little tend to rely
on own label and non branded goods for
the bulk of their sales meanwhile you've
got a growing competition between the
brands and really fierce promotion so
Easter eggs are getting cheaper for all
of us which is which is great news if
you like your chocolate and that's
really affecting the market leader which
is cabrón does that mean they're giving
a rubbish chocolate instead then well
it's it's it's cheaper that's for sure
you know these are market you know these
are challenging market conditions for
Mondelez and they've responded by
changing their recipe it's you know it
is a matter of taste whether whether you
prefer that the dairy milk chocolate or
the or that all the Cadbury chocolate
that they're using when it comes to it
though Rob if the public decide that
they don't like the taste and so they're
going to buy something else we have seen
providers of other products in the past
go back to their original recipe I'm
thinking particularly of what happened
perhaps with coca-cola yes we have seen
we have seen things like that happening
I think there's that like I said at the
beginning there's there's a there are
other factors which have affected
Cadbury much more than changing recipe
last year was a pretty early Easter
Sunday it fell on April April the fifth
I believe which means that the
confection has had a much narrower
window to sell all their goodies to us
this year is going to be an even
narrower win
Easter Sunday is falling at the end of
March which means we're going to see a
really hard full hard-fought few months
of trading between the confection isn't
between supermarkets okay so do you like
Easter eggs
do I like Easter eggs I'm not a big
chocolate eater actually on I don't eat
chocolate so it's no point in me asking
you whether you prefer the old or the
new cream eggs then no there's not fair
enough
thanks for joining us okay